[Musique]
on entend souvent dire que site web est
sécuritaire si l'adresse commence par un
HDPS et s'il y a un petit cadenas à côté
de la barre d'adresse
[Musique]
c'est vrai mais pas tard tout ce que ça
veut dire ce que la connexion entre
votre ordinateur et ce site Web là et
chiffré donc personne ne peut lire des
données qui passent du site à votre ordi
et vice-versa mais ça veut pas dire que
vous allez pas vous faire frauder ou
arnaquer en fait c'est assez facile
d'obtenir ce genre de certification de
sécurité pour votre site web qui
s'appelle un certificat SSL la preuve
selon la firme de cybersécurité fiche
Labs 74% des sites web de hameçonnage
avaient un certificat SSL en 2020 à
titre comparatif seulement 2% d'essai de
hameçonnage en avait un en 2016 donc les
choses ont changé assez rapidement bref
le https et le petit cadenas c'est pas
un gage de sécurité à 100%. mais s'ils
ne sont pas là visiter certainement pas
ce site là parce que ça veut dire qu'il
est pas sécuritaire
[Musique]
un vérifier l'URL souvent des sites
d'arnaques vont tenter de copier
l'apparence et le nom d'un site web
connu mais modifié certains petits
détails pour essayer de vous avoir par
exemple un haut peut devenir un zéro une
manière d'éviter un site web d'arnaque
comme celui-là c'est toujours se rendre
sur un site en faisant d'abord une
recherche sur Google pour le trouver 2
fait des recherches sur la réputation du
site web souvent des sites frauduleux
vont se faire signaler par des
internautes et des sites web spécialisés
comme virus total.com reçoivent des
signalements de leur communauté et
peuvent même scanner des sites avec un
antivirus pour savoir si est dangereux 3
entrez le nom du site web dans un outil
quiz ces outils gratuitement disponibles
sur Internet vous permettent de
connaître les informations
d'enregistrement d'un site souvent les
informations sont caviardées mais dans
bien des cas on peut savoir dans quel
pays le site web a été enregistré donc
par exemple si un site web prétendument
Canadien a été enregistré au Cameroun
ben c'est peut-être un signe que c'est
un site qui tente de vous arnaquer et
n'oubliez pas faites bien vos recherches